bonjour merci d'être en direct avec nous
sur rt france alors des attaques qui
interviennent dans un contexte déjà très
tendu on sait que le pays est fragilisé
par la guerre et ce qu'elle était
prévisible selon vous ces attaques
ces attaques étaient prévisibles dans le
sens où le 18 décembre dernier comme le
reportage l'a montré il ya une signature
d'un accord de gouvernement d'union
entre les séparatistes du sud et le
gouvernement officiel représenté par
manceau a dit sous l'égide de l'arabie
saoudite
donc finalement c'est cette signature
vise ce gouvernement d'union vise à
freiner à contrecarrer l'influencé et
les intérêts des outils au yémen
alors le gouvernement par la voix du
chef de la diplomatie a promis justement
de rétablir la stabilité au lendemain de
cette attaque on a l'impression que le
gouvernement d'union nationale suscite
une certaine méfiance actuellement riz
et mène la méfiance est de mise parce
que finalement ce gouvernement est un
peu fantoche le gras le président par
exemple président en arabie saoudite et
la popularité clairement très faible
compte tenu des alliances avec l'arabie
saoudite des émirats arabes unis qui ont
finalement qui sont intervenus au yémen
depuis 2015 et qui profite nalement que
les outils gagne en popularité gagne en
popularité face aux agissements de
l'arabie saoudite
alors on sait qu' il y à une enquête
préliminaire qui a été lancée suite à
cette attaque est selon d'ailleurs le
gouvernement
ça serait l'ami listes et des pussy qui
serait derrière ces attentats les
preuves et les détails on les a pas
encore mais comment justement savoir si
c'est bien les rebelles la poussie qui
sont à l origine comment les
caractériser le problème c'est que women
on a tendance à croire que c'est un
manichéisme politique entre soient les
outils soient les représentants du
gouvernement officiel
or il ya quand même la mouvance
jihadiste d'al qaïda l'état islamique
qui réside et où la présence est avérée
au sud du pays et à la frontière
saoudienne
donc il n'est pas non plus ça pourrait
également un attentat de la part de
cette mouvance djihadiste parce que les
outils de base ne vise pas les lieux
publics visent généralement les cibles
militaires saoudiennes alors vous l'avez
dit ryad a négocié un accord de partage
du pouvoir dans le sud un qui est
chapeauté justement par la formation de
ce nouveau gouvernement l'objectif
c'était de resserrer les rangs
aujourd'hui on a l'impression que le
yémen semble et surtout un pays
stratégique l'arabie saoudite l'iran se
taille la part du lion pour avoir une
emprise elle là bas comment l'expliquez
comment l'expliquer parce que de toute
manière ça fait déjà depuis 2015 les
liens entre les outils l'iran sont
avérés sont aucunément nier l'iran
apporte une aide de militaires
stratégiques logistique aux outils mais
les outils ne sont pas nécessairement
sont pas dans une logique pro-iranien
ils sont dans une logique premier
ministre ils cherchent à sanctuariser
finalement leurs acquis et territoriaux
sur le sol de on le voit par exemple ils
sont présents sur un quart du yémen qui
représente les trois quarts du yémen
utile alors que l'arabie saoudite
elle tente finalement par le biais du
gouvernement demande soir a dit de
contrebalancer finalement sept ans cette
influence et des intérêts routis la
région est ce qu'on peut s'attendre à
une recrudescence des violences sur le
terrain
les recrudescence en fait je pense qu'il
faudrait placer cet événement dans le
cadre plus régionale donc à savoir le
moyen orient
on le voit dernièrement il ya la
recrudescence des tensions la
recrudescence d'une surenchère militaire
à l'égard de l'iran notamment parce que
tous les analystes ou les experts
pensent que donald trump cherche la
guerre face à l'iran par le biais de
différentes tensions qui peut avoir que
ce soit en irak en syrie au liban et
même au yémen donc il est prévisible je
pense que dans les prochaines semaines
qu'il y ait une sorte de surenchère
militaire dans la région
donc ça risque d'être assez tendue
jusqu'à voulait en fait tous les
analystes pensent qu'une fois que joe
biden arrivera à la maison blanche
il y aurait une sorte d'apaisement des
tensions
mais je pense que joe biden va
assurément changer de forme dans le
discours mais papale aucunément changer
de fond en terme de politique étrangère
merci beaucoup alexandrine d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes analyste géopolitique du
moyen-orient